good evening guys this is a video about
studying multiple foreign languages and
how you can switch between those
different languages without getting
confused and mixed up if you've looked
at my channel before you've seen that
I've studied a number of different
foreign languages maybe you've studied a
number of different foreign languages
and maybe you've found it kind of
confusing or maybe you've found there's
some overlap between the language or
you've crossed wires between language
maybe it gets confusing when you study
more than one how do you keep them all
inside your head and be able to speak
more than a couple languages like five
six seven languages how do you do it
well keep in mind I'm talking from the
point of view of someone who's studied
all these foreign languages as an adult
I didn't learn any foreign language or
second language as a kid I was raised
monolingual just speaking English so
this is from that point of view of
learning as an adult someone who learned
it as a kid might be different to keep
that in mind okay so basically there are
three things I'll start with the first
one I think you really need to refine
your pronunciation for each of the
languages you really need to get
specific with your with the distinctions
you make in the phonology so really look
at all the different sounds in each
language and get them as as specific and
as precise as possible because I think a
lot of what causes crossover between
different languages is that you are
using the same phonology or similar
phonology for those languages when a
native speaker has a very precise
distinct phonology for that language so
this is something that my theory illness
came from studying a few different
languages I studied Hebrew and Arabic
which are quite related but the
phonology isn't that similar they're
quite different but also I've studied
French and I find that I've had a lot
more crossover between French and Hebrew
than between
Arabic and Hebrew even though French and
Hebrew are not related really and that's
because there are some sim
phonological sounds between Hebrew and
French that are that don't exist between
Hebrew and Arabic so that's caused some
of the crossover between them it's the
phonology it's the similar phonology so
in order to solve that problem I had to
really get precise with my phonology for
French and for Hebrew I had to look at
all the sounds look at exactly how to
pronounce those sounds that were causing
the confusion so you can do that I mean
when I say refine your pronunciation
it's in general focus on studying your
pronunciation and improving it get some
help from native speakers really focus
on emulating native speakers but also at
a more advanced level I'll teach you a
little technique that that helps people
take it to a more native level or near
native level the technique is this
imagine that a particular native speaker
is actually speaking through you it
might sound strange but there you're
kind of channeling a certain person
through your body and they're speaking
out your mouth like when I speak French
I imagine that Sarkozy key the former
president is speaking through me because
he's somebody that I modeled when I was
studying French I paid attention to his
pronunciation tried to copy his
intonation so when I speak French when
I'm trying to get precise with my
pronunciation I imagine it's him
speaking through me all right and when I
speak Tagalog I imagine a certain
Filipino person who I know who speaks
Tagalog I imagine that person is
speaking through me and by doing that
you are you're really your your brain is
picking up on a lot of very little
subtle cues in the pronunciation that
you can't pick up on consciously if you
try to focus on all those little
differences you can't really do it but
if you just focus on the whole person
your unconscious mind can't pick up on
all those little fine-tuned elements of
the pronunciation and help you out a lot
so that's one thing it's one trick you
can try for getting your pronunciation
to a more authentic level okay so focus
on the pronunciation that's my first
piece of advice the second thing is 100%
commitment no half-stepping 100
percent commitment when you are
switching into the next language okay so
when you are moving from one language
into the other it's kind of like you are
walking through a doorway into another
room if you enter the doorway and you
just stand in the doorway and try to
speak the other language of the other
room you're going to retreat into the
first room you're going to go back into
the other language or you're going to
get some crossover between the two
you'll find it hard to really move into
the second language so what you really
need to do is just make a firm decision
okay now I'm switching into the other
language I'm not going back into the old
one I'm walking through the doorway and
I'm closing the door behind me right to
your you're basically just completely
deciding I'm speaking this language now
and not the other you don't want to
switch back and forth so you want to
just lock the door behind you okay so
it's really just about pushing yourself
and making a firm commitment and when
you make that firm decision to speak
this one then it motivates you and
pushes you forward and takes you into
that zone of that language okay
so that's the second thing is just that
hundred percent decision okay I'm going
to speak French now I'm going to speak
Arabic now and completely cut off the
language you were speaking a moment
earlier all right so that's number two
number three is a little more abstract
and it's one that I don't use all that
often anymore but I used it I've tried
it in the past and made use of it when I
needed it and it's like this you imagine
a scene that you associate with the
language that you want to speak so for
example when I speak French
I might imagine a scene on the patio of
a cafe in Paris right and imagine all of
the the subtle little the subtle little
sensory cues that go along with that
like the taste of wine at the smell of
my my baguette and all that kind of
stuff
and hearing the ambience around me
hearing the French language spoken
around me so by doing that you are
you're creating a connection between the
language and that image so that whenever
you want to move into that that state in
which you you are speaking the language
well then you imagine that image and it
brings you into the zone of the
language okay so that's something you
can try another example of it when I
speak Hebrew I imagine the time I spent
in Jerusalem because that's a very vivid
time for me so I can bring myself back
to that time imagine the environment
imagine a certain situation I was in in
that place where I can hear Hebrew
speakers and I see different cultural
things that remind me of the Hebrew
language and all of that so all of those
things are associations that bring me
back into the zone when I was speaking
Hebrew well all of these pieces of
advice are kind of abstract I wish I
could be a bit more logical and
scientific in the tips I'm giving but
when we're dealing with we were dealing
with switching from one language to
another we're dealing with switching in
two different states and that kind of
requires you to take control of your
perception right it's not the same for
everybody so if these tips don't really
work for you then you don't have to use
them of course just but think about
similar types of techniques and how you
can control your perception in a way
that will take you into that zone where
you are speaking the language well so a
lot of it has to do with associations
and connections with that language
another thing I should point out is that
the languages that you haven't spoken
recently are always going to fade a
little bit if you leave them in the
background right the ones that you can
move into the most easily are the ones
you have used most recently so don't
expect to use one of these techniques
and be able to speak really well and
really really instantly in a language
you haven't spoken in five years you
might be able to with the basics of that
language but you won't be at the level
you were at five years ago obviously
because you you start to lose some of
the language gradually so just keep that
in mind it's also a matter of just
keeping the language fresh and keeping
them well practiced you can't always do
that with all of them if you speak ten
languages you can't speak all ten every
day so you'll always have some that are
more ready to go than others and the
others are more waiting in the
background for you to retrieve them and
start to practice and and brush up on
those languages and then they'll be in
the four
front and ready to get into the zone
again alright so that's all I got to say
about that hope that's clear
talk to you later